when I was three years old was when I
first developed the love of performance
my mother had helped me memorize twas
the night before Christmas and I
performed it for my father and it was in
that moment that psychiatrists or
psychologists say is the palimpsest
moment where you have this moment of
clarity and it was in that moment that I
said oh my this is what I want to do so
that was when it started it changed over
the years for for for very good reasons
but that was the actual moment
the development of myself as an actor
really started when i went to carnegie
mellon university in pittsburgh and i
was studying acting there and in the
brochure for the school it says this
course is as rigorous and exacting as
theater itself and they were not kidding
so that's really when the difficulties
started for me because here I was with
everybody who had been the star of their
high school play and so we were in this
milieu of about 60 people at the time
and we knew that at least half of us
would be cut my graduating class of
actors that had come in with me was 15
so it was a really rigorous program and
I thank God for it because it was an
amazing training program and so then I
left there and I went into Repertory
Theater and then it was at a certain
point that I knew it was time for me to
either go to New York or Los Angeles and
I called this extraordinary woman who I
had become friendly with at the TCG
auditions which are the theater
communications group auditions which is
really at the time where you went to be
to be seen by all the artistic directors
of all the repertory theaters all over
the country her name is rosemary
tischler and I called rosemary and I
said okay is it time for me to come to
New York and she said yes I think it is
and that really was a huge decision
because it was a decision that changed
my life and I thought that it would be
like it had been in repertory theater
that I would have all kinds of hearts
and that it would be easy and I would
audition and I would get it and then I
didn't and so I went through a real
crisis in the late 70s and I I I really
had to look at myself as a human being
first and as a performer second as to
what I really wanted because when I
wasn't getting what I thought I wanted
I've often said this to people I it was
really part temper tantrum
and part existential crisis because I
wasn't I didn't know what to do about
not getting what I thought I wanted and
it was in that moment in time I mean it
was over time but there was one specific
moment where I said I have to give up I
can't do this anymore I don't want to do
this anymore what is it how is it that
i'm contributing because i don't have an
experience of contributing i have an
experience of making a difference and i
don't like my life and is it going to
matter if i go somewhere and do
streetcar named desire is it going to
matter if i go somewhere and do another
place and where what is it what is it
all mean and it was at that time that
and I was completely broke and my my
agent called me and they said they want
you to audition for an understudy for a
soap opera and I said you don't
understand I'm never doing a soap opera
and and I said and by the way just so
you know I'm never doing a sitcom either
so just just to be really clear she said
well you have no money so it's three
hundred fifty dollars for the day if you
get it I said him there so I got it and
I didn't go on that day because the gal
who was playing the part was not ill
that day and so but I they did ask me to
audition for the role but as they did
had decided to replace her and they
asked me on the day that I came in to
understudy her they asked me what I
would do with this part if this were
where the part where to go and I thought
to myself this is interesting this this
format reaches a lot of people this
could be some way to make a difference
and also to make money because i was
living in new york city in new york city
with no money as everybody knows is
really it's tough and you can only live
so long and unemployment and i got it
they gave it to me and it changed my
life
so those were some of the things that
were were difficult times for me I mean
there's more but that's just sort of the
beginning of the of the of the process
of my becoming a different kind of
person in a different kind of actor not
the little girl who wandered her
father's approval but she was three
years old